- The over-promise of
what success looks like
is what's causing
people to lose.
(soft music)
It leads to a bigger
conversation of self-awareness.
I think the biggest mistake
most of us make is we
hope who we are instead
of auditing who we are.
- [Man] Okay.
- [Gary] Like everybody
wants to be somebody.
- Look I really want to be the
fucking quarterback of
the New York Jets but
truth is, I don't
have it like that.
Like I don't have those pieces.
And I think everybody
believes that they can be
an entrepreneur,
a businessperson--
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Gary] and the truth is
there's a ton of kids right now
who could be the number two,
number three or number four.
The number six guy at Facebook
made a fuck load of money.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Gary] And right now that guy
and that gal because of
all the entrepreneurship talk
is trying to start a company.
There're a lot of people
especially when they were built
to be good students and be
good number fours and sevens
that when the go to be a one
and after a life full of winning
because they
understood that system
they go into the
actual marketplace,
no more rich friends and
families and connections
and private school
and good universities.
Nobody gives a fuck
who your dad is.
It's almost like
when rap got big.
Everybody just decided that
they were gonna be a rapper.
You can't just decide you're
gonna an entrepreneur.
I think a lot of people have
been extending their
college lives and disguising
it as entrepreneurship.
I worked fucking
hard for my money.
I came here with zero.
I didn't have a single
fucking vacation day
or weekend since
I was in the seventh grade.
I'm not pumped
about losing my money.
You have a lot of people
that are built DNA-wise and
skill-wise and have studied
and went through school
and have been formed
and have trained to be
unbelievable consultants at
Bain and McKinsey
and other places,
have a great career,
and then get involved
in entrepreneurial ventures
where they can leverage
the monies they made
and invest and
things of that nature
who are starting consumer
apps out the gate and
have no fucking clue how
to be a true-bred entrepreneur
because they don't
have the stomach to deal
when the market says
"Go fuck yourself."
I think that we've just
lived through the Golden Era
of people saying
they were entrepreneurs
but what they were was
they were operators
that were building machines
A.K.A. companies that were
built for financial arbitrage.
People have been building
startups that are predicated
on raising the next round.
You've been building your
company for user growth
to raise your next round.
You're not building a company.
We are lacking
self-awareness in this space
in a very substantial way.
And there's a lot of people
that are about to met with
a lot of disappointment,
and are stuggling
and one thing we're not
talking about is the
level of success.
Everybody thinks they
have to build fucking Uber.
Everybody thinks they have
to make millions of dollars.
It's unbelievable
what we've done and
I absolutely want
to make sure that
we're starting to have
real conversations.
Making $100,000 a year
that's massively successful.
We need to recalibrate
what success looks like
in our space because we're
forcing through the branding of
what we're doing
very impractical, very high risk,
very low return results
for so many 'cause
everybody is shooting
for $10 billion.
And if we keep telling
everybody that it's
so easy to do it.
And if we don't start talking
about that the entry level
to be in the top 1% earners in
America is only $400,000 a year.
And I use the word only
because nobody here is
even in the mindset of
million dollar or bust, right?
We need to start
having proper conversations.